[Music]
in multiple attack news submitted by
scam likely that was clean an octopus
sucked onto a vloggers face and ripped
her skin when she tried to eat it live
on camera
I thought feature in it look hilarious
I'd watch it cuz I knew we were gonna do
it for JK news good the octopus ripped
the skin off yeah that's C I don't even
know you could do that delicate is our
[ __ ] skin cuz every time I'm in a
Japanese you won't we went to the
Japanese fish market oh yeah something
grabbed and just ripped them off their
arms and stick them into the bag before
my face Gators roughest [ __ ] you feel my
face yeah true men's skin is public
because you guys have to shave oh I
don't know about David
I don't fuchsia you got it you got a
shave I shave I shave once a week where
huh I just shaved two days ago
I've 18 I have eighteen hairs here and I
about 36 here pretty good thank you
are we gonna watch 36 chambers sucking
yes so we are going to watch the video
that was going viral in China this
Chinese platform I can't even read it
Xing xao okay fine I'll try it's wash
wash you and I you butchered it and you
just made the whole cut you dissed the
whole country
it's like 1/7 the world sorry
okay here we go how did you say you've
been to China well it it's kua I Sh oh
you Sai why shall it's hard without the
accents cuz it could be so she's like I
can't read it because it's in English
but if it was the Chinese she was no
yeah the disclaimer that's hard without
the accent yeah I mean this is still a
national Mexican you should know better
you're sitting next to me you should be
worried oh here we go
oh you think it was like holding on and
had it's like mouth it was like biting
and I thought yeah I think of the bee
that looks like a full-sized octopus it
doesn't look like a baby octopus thank
you how are you planning on eating it
she was gonna eat it raw
also by the way this is super [ __ ]
popular like the Chinese mukbang thing
yeah it's super popular right now
because there's a few girls that have
been eating a lot of weird [ __ ] like
there's this one girl that just eats
anything and everything so she's really
playing into the whole like Asian people
will eat everything she had this you
know beer for China is just regular Mia
yeah you know that oh she had a hot
plate and they she put a glass on there
like a clear glass with hot oil in it so
it kind of heats through and then she
was boiling like [ __ ] warms or some
[ __ ] issues so this it's like hot right
now where they're just eating the most
disgusting [ __ ] on these mug box that's
weird
I mean I guess I the next level [ __ ]
because everybody's eating dope [ __ ]
they're like well why don't I see the
butthole then let me show you next slow
as another level it's definitely a side
level working up to that goal you know
like the best pastries in that what's
next you know those huge [ __ ] maggots
those white worms like tomato hornworms
are in the Lion King yes that [ __ ] all
like some [ __ ] grubs you find one
yeah they're eating that yeah right no
they would be Friday right they do look
kind of juicy though Oh King me that if
you if you could eat a silkworm you
could probably eat a silkworm is
disgusting to me you Venus Oh quark yeah
in Korean is kapa biggie so yeah we have
a dried silkworm we ate a dried so
that's a I [ __ ] pretended a buggy is
gusting but it's like one of those
dishes that it's an acquired taste and
not that I don't think a lot of people
eat that [ __ ] because that's some
country [ __ ] live octopus is an acquired
thing in general the like have you have
you know life I ate it it's actually
pretty good yeah I liked it baby other
baby ones the one thing you gotta like
cut up in front of you and then you dip
it in like the sauce and oil star salt
and oil but nobody eats the huge one
like that dad yeah I bet it tastes the
same though except for in the movie old
boy oh yeah isn't that crazy
octopus camouflaged itself with the skin
color maybe it's just like octopus is
regular but that she's just pale
clothing that's so crazy
well like oh this is a great color
palette that where is its head do you
see its head you know what so cuz it
looks like it's bye it was biting her
yeah she was being again either being
[ __ ] crazy of a beat
yeah like a bird yes that's their mouth
she's disgusting it's crazy it's [ __ ]
disgusting and first of all she's a
great entertainer because as she was
crying she still had tie the point of
the chemical she's the holding on to I'm
like let go of the [ __ ] perpetrator
because wouldn't you close your eyes if
it was pulling like yeah I would that
would be a natural reaction to go like
this
she's an entertainer yeah but she was
opening it even more she stayed in frame
she didn't fall out of frame or anything
you know it's funny so when the octopus
finally came off they're saying that she
said my face is disfigured
I'll eat it in the next video cuz it
wasn't that bad she was gonna like I
cook it up and eat the octopus 30
minutes later the Hello Kitty band-aid
Phil Roth - octopus know she was live
streaming this I cannot make it go to
waste
we don't have the beginning part of it
oh she yeah he's really nice though I
think if my animal attacked me and I
hurt my natural instinct after I pulled
it off with to be slamming on the ground
was already to eat it beat it up like it
was already gonna be like eaten out of
him my natural instinct yes sir I don't
know if I could do a whole you do what
there's times I accidentally step on
your toe and then he punched me like I
did it on purpose I don't do that you
have a natural reaction I do that
[ __ ] I do that when you go you go
like that cuz I should have heard no
there's times I got something on the
couch and a puppet scene you're like oh
never oh I don't know who's telling the
truth because you could by accident
bumper but with like his masts that
might be like a regular plan yeah yeah
also you got to you know she's also a
big [ __ ] so she could take it like a
lot that takes a real girl it actually
tastes like octopus tastes like pig ear
like cartilage it does taste like on
cartilage it's delicious it's kind of
got fat and cartilage together
I feel like cartilage is more of a
feeling meditate Bob yeah it's more the
sauce yeah it's yeah the cartilage is
feeling in your mouth noises dead like
it didn't snot moving anymore or the the
rigor mortis is done or whatever it's
just the same thing you know and what
Korean people eat those baby octopi
[ __ ] octopuses right octopi sauce
they they they chop it up so it's it's
technically dead but the nerves are
still there so it's moving around that
thing was straight up yeah live octopus
I heard a lot of restaurants in Korea
don't do the full-on live anymore
because people choke
yeah they die for me yeah if you don't
shoe it well enough then it gets me a
throw and still Wiggles around in a way
and it sticks to things but it supposed
to be small that's what they tell you
they tell you when they when you cut it
up and you eat it you have to chew the
crap out of it and so yeah and I don't
want a big wad of that shake and nobody
wants yeah
well would have been tight is if the
octopus started jujitsu in her hair oh
my god tangled in there and she got to
shave her head or something to rip her
hair out after Jitsu yeah I'm actually
like salivating right now I might not do
the live octopus again or door slamming
fresh octopus is so [ __ ] good dude
you ever had fresh octopus like cuz at
the same restaurant that me and Bart
went to my first and they'll get some of
the live octopus and then they'll chop
it up and it'll put some inside of the
soup and in the [ __ ] tentacles is
what you eat right but when we have
fresh octopus the fresh live one it's
like I've never had anything that
delicious before live like a fresh one
like one that was alive ten seconds are
going to cook that [ __ ] it is
really good walking good the issue in
the you can't like see the food you're
about to eat all the seafood restaurants
they come out with a lobster they're
like oh you want this one that makes it
way better yeah food but not like a cow
yeah conditional single [ __ ] cow I
used to raise bunnies in like sell em to
so people could cook up in [ __ ] and then
one time he like killed one in front of
me but I looked away right before it
died oh I can't remember but yeah back
you looked away after it died you like
could not eat that that rabbit suit you
hey lady
Oh rabbits rabbits uh kissy die I I
think they're really cute but there's no
chicken to like with me you know what it
is it's the eyeballs you can't see it
like you know to me you can see into
their souls this is a window to your
soul you can see the eyeballs it's hard
to see off the seafood so like clam like
it is what it is I could see alive I
don't know if I'm eating the same thing
I saw the closer it is to human the more
we are toward the creature so like mad
whites of eyes you see the whites of
idea yeah what if you put some
sunglasses on a bunny you shake that
fool that hello personality it's more
human clothes on a cow sir Graham
[ __ ] famous that oh my mouth
make sure to [ __ ] tipsy this buddy
[Laughter]
sunglasses on the pixelated ones with
like this one
yeah just one of those things [ __ ] do
you [ __ ] rabbit like this yeah I
think mammals are hard cuz they're furry
and cute no that [ __ ] I think it's
seeing them alive and in the process of
them dying that like that right there
that chunk I can't see because I could
see that one thing like skinning them
and all that I'm like you're part handle
that but do you think that makes you
normal yeah
why me that makes it sensitive Americans
right I don't want to stress them out so
we have bunnies where we live right now
I was moving my car two days ago and
there was a bunny that's maybe like four
or five feet away from me and I have a
tendency to want to catch animals so I
saw that oh [ __ ] I'm a cache distant
[ __ ] but then I was like man [ __ ] the
minute I grabbed him I know he's gonna
think he's gonna misunderstand me he's
gonna think I'm trying to eat him but
I'm not I just wanna pet him and I just
imagine him being stressed you know made
by a bunny before I know it's not it's
[ __ ] painful a bunny have you been
bit by me if I get hurts it's pretty
painful
this one does pick everything up we were
doing a music video out of park one day
and he just in the middle of the shoot
he just picked up the goose and started
petting it was within a 5 it wanted it
you know I have to catch him in the air
the funny thing is it's that you know
like when kids do this [ __ ] when they're
really young
their parents usually stop them and tell
them no nobody has told them no yet
that's the same [ __ ] a little
two-year-olds black pants are just like
let's see if he does it this time
[Music]